ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
for coming today
this is 60 minutes news conference that
we will begin very shortly but I will
first ask each of the participants to
make brief opening remarks we will then
open for questions please wait for one
of the roving mics to get to you before
you ask your questions before asking
your question please state the Nate your
name and affiliation the organization
you're here representing today we will
ask that you ask one question only
please no follow-up questions until
everyone has had a chance to ask
questions and I would also ask one
question per organization I know we have
multiple representatives from the same
organization here today we will start by
opening remarks with mr. Warren Buffett
explain the mechanics which are on the
website the letters have been put up on
the Berkshire Hathaway dot-com website
what and slightly complicated because
Berkshire Hathaway has an a stock and a
beef stock
the a stock can be converted into 30
shares of B I'll talk in terms of B
throughout this and I have roughly 14
and a quarter million shares of B stock
and by letters which were delivered
earlier today I've committed 12 million
and 50,000 shares they're earmark held
by me but every July I will be giving a
million shares to the Bill of Melinda
Gates Foundation did I say 10 million of
them is it a 10 million and a million
church to the Susan Thompson Buffett
foundation and 350,000 shares each to
the three foundations headed by my
children Susan Howard and Peter and that
will continue throughout my lifetime
subject to the only two
one that at least one of Bill and
Melinda being active in their foundation
and then I will arrange in my will to
have one of several methods that could
be used to accomplish that after my
death and and incidentally the balance
of the be shares that I'm keeping will
go to philanthropy either during my
lifetime or my death and as we go along
if you have any questions about how this
will operate be delighted answer I just
wanted to start by saying bill and I are
absolutely honored and humbled by
Warren's gift it's really unprecedented
in terms of what we can do to do good in
the world and it's something that we
take very seriously we haven't feel
incredible responsibility I think when
you give away your own wealth it's one
thing but to give away the body of
somebody else's life work is really
quite something
so it's something that we look forward
to working with Warren on as a trustee
we have a great management team in place
that the foundation will obviously have
to expand that somewhat and grow the
foundation a bit over time but I think
you what you should expect from us is
that we'll really deep in the areas that
were already into we're not going to
broaden the foundation a whole lot of
new areas but really deepen what our
commitment already to global health and
particularly to education so I know bill
and I are delighted not only about the
gift but in particular about getting to
work with Warren and we're very very
excited about it just a few quick things
we've known Warren since 1991 and it was
his thought that well should go back to
society that got us thinking about doing
our foundation in the first place and as
that's grown we've had a chance to share
how that's worked out I remember one
time in 2001 where I got to give a talk
to Warren and some of his friends about
global health and you know how excited I
was about the opportunity to do
something their Global Health is one of
the two big causes the foundation goes
after education broadly defined
including scholarships and libraries in
the United States is the sac
and as Melinda said we're gonna deepen
accelerate now what we do around those
areas we'll pick some things that also
touch on the same things of dealing with
poverty or dealing with opportunity for
everyone and so it's a big challenge for
us to make sure that this money gets
used in the right way but one that we're
we're thrilled about and thrilled that
will have Warren as our third trustee so
you've seen the three trustees that the
foundation here and we're gonna do our
best job to have have as much impact as
possible certainly these problems are
gigantic and so it's not only what we do
but what we do with our partners what we
encourage other people to do in the
partnership often that we have with with
governments so with that I'll let Joe
move to the questions down here in front
please wait for the mic scott kohn from
CMU see it's our this is Ron
I mean it's question for all of you I'm
wondering if you can take us through the
the process the mental process of going
from accumulating wealth which all of
you have done to giving it away at what
point do you decide it's time to stop
accumulating and start giving away and
how did that process work for each of
you well my original thought and it was
a thought that was developed with my
wife 50 years ago was that I would
accumulate it through my lifetime and I
thought the odds were good that she
would survive me and that we we always
were agreed that it would all go back to
society but we thought the odds were
good that she would be the one that
implemented that I had this theory which
she regarded as a rather a convenient
theory that philanthropic needs would
always be with us and they would today
tomorrow 20 years from now 50 years from
now and that if money was destined to go
to philanthropy that the people who were
high compounders with money should be
the ones to take care of the twenty and
fifty years from now and the ones would
be the low compounders should be the
ones that would be taking care of
today's needs like like I say she
rather convenient cuz she also that's
what I wanted to do anyway but she died
before I did so I then was faced either
with the choice of letting it run till
the end of my life
or doing something currently and since I
had a sensational solution for doing it
now that better than a I could have
imagined
I have selected these five foundations
all of which you have their own
strengths to implement this I if you're
accumulating wealth it's very natural or
if you wish to community well to go to
somebody you think and handle money
better than you can an investment
manager of some sort whomever it may be
and and turn turn your money over to
them and say you know you can do a
better job than I can do make me some
money well I've got some people where
I'm saying you can give it away better
than I can so I'm turning it over to you
and and and and you do a better job of
giving it away than I would this
question you know it's been very
exciting to be part of a business that's
both been successful and had so much
impact and a Microsoft is something I'll
always have a incredible connection to
including being totally full-time the
next two years and then moving over to
spend full time on the foundation I'm
surprised how similar the work is in
terms of taking great people and being
very optimistic and and looking out
long-term there's some differences as
well but you know I I love both and you
know now it's even more evident that if
I work hard that there's the resources
to have an impact and of course I'm
thrilled that I get to do that together
with Melinda and I think you had
originally thought that maybe it would
be later in your life that you would
start to give away but as we got more
involved we got involved solely just at
the beginning with Bill's dad and then
eventually we got into libraries hooking
up libraries with computers but the more
deeply you get involved in the work and
more you see the needs and the
inequities that are out there the more
you want to do for these causes and I
think that builds on itself and we've
really gone very close to these issues
and feel like there's work that can be
done today to start solving some of the
issues
I'm wondering a few kin disorder what if
you can be a little more specific at all
about what you'll be doing with global
health focusing on the top three that
you have been but you've mentioned
something about a few other things in
that area well as you know today we
already focus as you said on hiv/aids
tuberculosis and malaria those are the
big three that we focus on in addition
we've been doing some work more recently
with rotavirus and we're starting to go
down the list of other diseases you'll
see that when there are diseases where
we see that there's a medication out
there that can already have an effect we
will start to get involved in some of
those areas but we look very much at
what diseases have the greatest impact
on lives where can you save the most
lives so for instance there is a drug
parallel myosin which in 2006 will
hopefully become the first drug that the
foundation in partnership with our
grantee Institute for one World Health
will hopefully bring to places like
India and Bangladesh where they have a
disease called calles our black fever
that we really can save about 200,000
lives a year if you can get this drug
out there at a much lower cost and the
drugs that are available today so those
are some of the areas that you'll start
to see as pushing is is good bit a bit
down on that list of infectious diseases
beyond just the big three yeah all our
key role is is where the market isn't
going to come in and and come up with a
solution so that means the diseases that
are in the developing countries are not
in the rich countries and that list is
overwhelmingly infectious diseases and
all the top 20 we have some activities
obviously scaled to the the size of the
problem over here gentleman in the red
shirt
for mr. Buffett my name's Sean Macarthy
I'm with The Globe and Mail from Toronto
can you comment at all on what impact if
any you expect your decision to have on
Berkshire Hathaway and particularly as
you as you liquidate the shares do you
expect that that to have any impact on
share value yeah I I wouldn't I wouldn't
have done this if I thought there was
going to be a negative impact and
Berkshire trades less the most big cap
stocks in fact it may be the lowest
turnover on the New York Stock Exchange
as a percentage of shares outstanding
and one of the complaints we get
occasionally from institutional
investors is the is the fact that it is
not as liquid as you would think a
company would be with the market cap
that we have so the turnover a Berkshire
which has been about 15% a year if all
of the stock I give away gets sold every
year would move up to 17% and as you
know there are many stocks on their
exchange with over a hundred percent so
I think it's I see no downside to that
they're certainly going to be no
downside in terms of my enthusiasm or
energies that devoted to the job I mean
I love the job of running Berkshire
either I hate to tell you how much I
love it because the shareholders can get
me to pay to have the job
I don't want that word to get out but
over time I actually think it also makes
it a little more likely that that that
which is immaterial to me but some of
our shareholders are interested in it it
makes it makes it more likely that
Berkshire would be included in the S&P
500 we're probably four times the size
of of the next largest company that is
not included and one reason is the lack
of turnover and over time this will this
will make for a more active stock and I
see nothing that on the horizon remotely
that would cause it to diminish the
intrinsic value per share of the company
and and if anything I mean we've got 30
we will have 31 percent of the profits
of Berkshire in effect that are being
totally committed to charity and I don't
I don't know that I could work any
harder particularly at what I do then I
do
that thought will not will motivate me
shut them in the blue jacket Thank You
mr. Buffett mr. mrs. gates a question
the mario Platinum's or a u.s. senator
for in sullivan tick what road which
like the Financial Times or Italy in
Italy some people would consider that
mr. mafia would be crazy to give away
the money instead of giving it to your
children so what message would you give
also to other countries that are not so
much into this mode and also did you
think about giving the money to the US
government is also from mr. gates
you know governments governments in a
way do take care of I don't think
anybody's crazy to and people do leave
their money occasionally to the
government on death
you really got a few a couple of choices
you can you can you can leave a
significant portion you can leave all of
it to the government a few if you
elected to do that
you can elect a method of distributing
your state that leaves a significant
portion to the government and a
significant portion to do other people
or you can elect to do it through a
philanthropic organization I think that
in terms of the 40 odd billion that my
Berkshire shares are worth now I think
that the Bella Melinda and also the
people involved in the other four
foundations will do a far better job in
terms of maximizing the good that comes
out of that money then would happen if
it were dropped into the federal
treasury kind of that well you'll get a
chance to judge that over time but I
think I I used I have used the the Gates
Foundation as an example when I talk to
students of a terribly successful
organization that would per dollar spent
as also is true with the susan thompson
Buffett foundation per dollar spent I
think the results are are terrific and
in terms of improving the lives of
people around the world so
that's that would be my choice other
people can look and see how this turns
out and and maybe maybe they will find a
model that they want to emulate if the
results are as good as I anticipate they
will be I think I'll add to that that we
think the land to be is something that
is is a choice that people make but we
want to show people that it can be a lot
of fun and it can have a lot of impact
and so we think you know whatever
country it is we'd like to to encourage
more philanthropy on the end in the
second round
Amanda Gordon with the New York Sun you
introduce yourselves as the three
trustees I'm wondering about a possible
fourth that's very well known in New
York Mayor Bloomberg he's expressed an
interest in devoting his life after
office two to philanthropy and he also
has an interest in public health as you
do have you spoken to him have you been
in talks about his joining your venture
I not recently but over the I think
perhaps five years ago I was well before
it was in office he and I talked about
philanthropy and the whole idea of what
you do with your state I'm not I mean
his record in philanthropy is
extraordinary I mean he he enjoys giving
away money and he enjoys giving away
money intelligently on a big scale wide
scale I admire what he's done I admire
what he's done as a mayor of New York
too but I admire what he's done as a
philanthropist but he I've had no
conversations with him about this recent
action at all probably no we work here
in New York City in one of the biggest
high school programs we've got is here
in New York City because of Mayor
Bloomberg and his partnership with Joel
Klein one of the big things that they're
trying to do and we're doing in
conjunction with them we're working in a
lot of the New York schools to try and
raise the graduation rates and we're
seeing some success there where kids who
graduated before the schools were
graduating about 30% of their students
in high school were now graduating
around 80% of students in some of these
new high schools so we think they're in
a great spot where they are right now to
be doing the work in education
we're excited about partnering with them
yeah so I'd say you know we have a lot
of interests in common whether it's you
know he's given money for malaria he
believes in education so I don't know in
what form but I'm sure we'll find a way
to partner with them one way or another
cuz it's it's great working with smart
people like Mayor Bloomberg that to the
left side of the room okay go ahead and
look jail get your words right wanted to
get back to your children mr. Buffett
seriously what did they do wrong could
they bring curfew tell us a little bit
please about your philosophy about
handing down billions to children yeah I
don't believe in creating dynastic
wealth my children have all received
money from me and my wife they'll
receive more on my death but they did
they are in the privileged top 1% at
least of the population perhaps at the
top tenth of one percent even but I
don't I don't I don't really believe
that a society that aspires to be
meritocratic and and that believes in
equality of opportunity my kids have had
an advantage the over 99% of the kids in
the country is a whole combination of
things even if they weren't given any
money they've had a huge advantage I I
don't think it's in keeping with this
isn't in keeping with my view of how the
world should operate to create huge
amounts of dynastic wealth I really
believe that in terms of having equality
of opportunity in this country and the
right people in the right job doing the
right things I don't think they should
inherit my position in society any more
than if I was on the Olympic team 20
years ago as the 100-meter dash which
will be a little hard for some of you to
imagine but they should they should
inherit my bike position you know in
2008 or if I was quarterback at Nebraska
football team 60 years ago which again
is hard to imagine I I do not believe in
inheriting your position in society
based on what room you come from they
didn't do it well they did a few things
wrong but they didn't cure things wrong
that I did at our age I'll put it that
way I
enormous ly proud of them I am they are
going to have the equivalent of a
billion dollar foundation Egypt I have
seen what they have done in the
philanthropic arena both in terms of
what they've gotten involved in and how
they've gotten involved in it and I
couldn't be more proud j-jake Business
Week building Linda do you by virtue
this gift you're gonna have to give away
significantly more money every year do
you have you thought about or do you
worry about the mechanics of doing that
efficiently and effectively by just
literally handing out that amount of
money each and every year
well it is something that you know just
in the last few months we've started to
talk about a bit and start to plan for
it inside the foundation and think a
little bit about what we might do and
we've always been as a foundation we
always have ideas that are germinating
inside the foundation that bill and I
will say to the foundation even two
years ago with our own money hey you
know here's a list we're kind of
constantly have what I call the top 30
list of if we were gonna deepen our work
where might we go and we start working
on that list pretty early so we've been
doing some small grants in the areas of
microlending the last few years we will
continue to deepen that learning and
probably expand out in microlending
we've been doing looking quite a bit of
looking and research in the area of
Agriculture and what biotechnology does
with agriculture particularly following
on what the Rockefeller Foundation has
done so we will deepen the work of
particularly in a lot of our health
areas to surround what we're doing
already in medicines and we've always
known that the medicines that we're
working on the vaccines were working on
eventually we're gonna have to get those
into large-scale trials and that's
always gonna have required a great deal
of money so we'll have that coming
forward and then we'll be surrounding
those programs by deepening them and
also figuring out how to deliver a lot
of these medicines in vaccines so I
think you'll see us push in those areas
it's fair to say that the size of the
problems that we're taking on whether
it's in the global arena broadly or in
education we think that we can wisely
take an and even more than double the
impact we have you know in some ways the
early successes we have now give us the
opportunity to scale up using the
amazing resources that that Warren's
made available so it'll be hard work to
make
sure it's all well spent it means
doubling over the next three years up to
over three billion a year of giving but
we're we're we're gonna do that and
we'll do our best to make sure it it's
all well spent the Bloomberg third row
and then gentlemen to your left after
that a pimp Fox of Bloomberg News
wealthy individuals of banding together
to do good I was wondering if each one
of you could comment on whether you
think this is a trend and do you
encourage more people to band together
and to effect effectively solve some of
these problems as a group rather than
individually and also a mr. Buffett
joining your your board as a trustee do
you think that more people will want to
join your board now well I I do think
you know just as when we buy companies
we we don't buy them because we think we
can provide better management we look
for management in place and then join
with them and and I mentioned in an
investment management you look for
people that can manage money and people
turn money over them freely I would hope
that people who were themselves unsure
of what they want to do in the area
philanthropy but know they want to
participate would look around it doesn't
have to be the Gates Foundation it can
be anybody whose activities they admire
in that field and join it with them why
not I mean it the chance to join approve
an organization where people are
basically working for nothing and that
have learned something along the way and
putting up their own money I mean it's a
it's that's I would think that will
appeal to some people and I really hope
this example perhaps causes that to
catch on in some quarters on the other
hand I've no objection to people doing
it themselves if they think they get the
best job done by themselves I think it's
also important to say that you know the
Foundation's already talk and work a lot
together I mean we're working with
Michael and Susan Dell already on Texas
high schools particularly in math and
science we're working with Eli Broad and
education learning a lot of what he's
done there
we're partnering with the David and
Lucile Packard Foundation some delivery
work that they've done in India two
states in India were particularly
interested in using the network that
they have to get medicines out so the
Foundation's do partner and talk I don't
think you have to sit on one another's
board to do that kind of thing and even
throughout time and we were the New York
Public Library this morning you know
that was Carnegie and aster and Bigelow
together who put together that
incredible Library System for New York
so I think it's been done throughout
time maybe you get these fluxes in
history where it comes together more and
this might be one of them but I think we
all have the same goal of doing good in
the world yes I I think the key thing is
to get more of the people who are super
lucky to think about giving back and
either backing people who have way of
doing that or having them come up with
something that they'll they'll put their
energy into we'd like to see more more
and I think there is a slight trend in
that direction Ted Turner started off by
kind of scolding people and that was a
good thing we're trying to complement
that by showing how much fun it can be
and then again of the gentleman right
here in third round Fred Katayama of
Reuters television the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation is already by far the
largest foundation in the world 30
billion strong now you're going to
double the size with mr. Buffett's
donation are you concerned having
experience on the business end with
antitrust about the concentration of
wealth albeit in the field of
philanthropy and mr. Buffett did you
give any thought to this before you made
your decision you could have spread the
wealth around to other places yeah and
there are five foundations involved but
you're right though that you have to
think about whether what activities are
scalable and whether some actually
become more effective with scale where
where if you're double the size you can
accomplish more than double the results
I've watched the Gates Foundation for a
number of years I think in their field I
would I would be amazed if results
diminished of proportional to capital
I wouldn't be surprised available funds
I wouldn't be surprised if actually they
became more efficient more effective per
dollar spent in doubling the funds you
know there's there's no question that
you know if you if if your interest was
you know taking care of stray cats and
you decided you're going to triple
somebody's foundation that you might not
feel like you'd accomplish a hell of a
lot at the end of the day but when
you're taking when you've got billions
of people who've been dealt a terrible
hand in life around the world with
really hundreds of millions with with
with with health problems of one sort or
another that in a great many cases could
be prevented that is not something that
three billion dollars a years too much
money for it's up to us and and to work
with the management team inside the
foundation to make sure that we build
advisors and around our programs we're
not gonna have advisors that advise the
whole foundation but advisors around
specific areas so we already do that for
instance in the Grand Challenges for
helps there are 20 scientists outside of
the foundation who sit out of the 22
seats 20 are held by outside scientists
who review every single one of those
grants and give comments to those grants
and we see those comments when we're
making decisions on things so and that's
true of all of our programs we build
specialists in outside of the foundation
to give us comments and review on that
and we'll have to make sure we continue
to do that and as we deepen our work if
we go into microlending or we go into
agriculture we'll have people who have
already been working in that well we've
already learned a great deal from the
Rockefeller Foundation who's been
working on AG bio for many many years
they're the ones who started the Green
Revolution they're out in 20 countries
already well you better believe we're
out talking with them partnering with
them taking their lessons learned and
saying okay what else would you all do
if you were gonna come in and broaden
your work or expand it even deeper so
we'll continue to do that over time with
the foundation there was a there was a
will by a woman who was the heir to the
Bell Ridge of oil one of five or six
when Belridge oil was sold out and she
left her money for the indigent
paraphrasing of Marin County in
California and they really were having
trouble to almost import indigents so
there are things that don't scale up
believe me when you talk about health
and educate
you do not have a problem scaling off
woman in blue Susan Dempsey on
Philanthropy calm mr. Buffett in your
interview unfortunate you spoke about
the need to make mistakes sometimes in
philanthropy and I wonder if you can
comment on the value of being able to
take risks sure it is true that in
business I look for easy things to do I
mean I I've found that that you get
pages as well for stepping over one foot
bars it's trying to clear a seven foot
bar and there's no degree of difficulty
adjustment for your for your if you make
a million dollars and you did it by a
plain vanilla dive into the pool you get
paid the same as if you did a triple
gainer off the high board so you look
for easy things in business easy
businesses to understand you know strong
market positions whatever it may be
philanthropy is just the opposite you
are tackling problems that have resisted
great intellect and lots of money often
I mean you know these are people these
are important problems people have
thought about them before you and people
many times spent money on them and you
are going to make mistakes you're going
to have failures you're going to be
disappointed with some people and and it
it's the nature of the game and I in my
letter to my three children that is on
the internet you know I told them don't
don't just go for saf projects I mean
you can bat a thousand in this game if
you want to by doing nothing important
or you'll that's something less than
that if you take on the really tough
problems but there's there's actual
value and things like education in terms
of doing things that don't work because
you were saving society from repeating
those mistakes you know in the future
and if you try five models and four
don't work the the fifth can be very
valuable and maybe you'll try five and
five won't work and then you've got to
try five more I mean that these are not
easy problems and and if you haven't a
total non tolerance for mistakes
you know you're gonna be very unhappy in
the business
but it's you're doing important things
and the occasional home run that can be
replicated by other people in society
will make far overshadow the cost of the
mistakes a great example of that is that
you I thought before we got into this
that somebody would be funding a malaria
vaccine or an AIDS vaccine in a very big
way and yet those are so rich such risky
projects where you don't know how long
it'll take
you know it'll take longer than a
politicians term it'll may take a lot
more money
they're just institutionally it was no
organization that was there to kind of
be at the center of taking that on and
so that's the kind of that's a very
risky thing we can't tell you when any
of those things work we've got enough
irons in the fire that you know we think
we're backing many different approaches
because of the the importance but you
know we will have many many failures in
drug discovery
we'll have feathers in new school
designs but every one of those will be a
lesson to it
daga McDowell at the Fox News Channel
this cement set that your children will
not be getting the vast bulk of your
fortune how did you break it to them
that you're gonna give this money away
to Bill and Melinda what was their
reaction and Bill and Melinda what was
your reaction when you found out how did
he tell you and what was your reaction
when you found out you're getting the
money well my kids view was elation I
mean they they've known all along that
my views on inherited wealth and share
them the the idea of having considerably
more resources to work with in terms of
their own philanthropic interests got
them enormous ly excited and and I think
they'll you know they'll do a terrific
job with them they have they have money
that most people would dream of you know
and although they were lucky and and in
that aspect of their of when they
selected their parents
but I I think they've been you know I I
I put in the fortune article but you
know I think that a rich person should
leave their children up so they can do
anything but not enough so they can do
nothing I mean I think the idea that you
have descended after descendant after
descendant that can command the
resources of society with these claim
checks that you leave them for decades
to come and command them the the labor
of other people and so on I did I I
don't think it's the proper way to run a
society and I'm delighted my kids have
that they were fortunate and when I was
when I was growing up when they were
growing up some more or less
simultaneously I thought when they were
growing up you know we were not known as
a fabulously rich family and we weren't
bad it was they raised a bit at the time
so so they've had an existence that
that's quite consistent with the way
they live now they live very well and
they consider themselves lucky they
don't consider themselves quite as lucky
as if they'd had a father with a
different view I think it's important to
say first of all that the money is not
coming to us it's being entrusted to us
to give back to society that that's what
we what it represents our duty to the
foundation and Bill and I really live
our lives with the belief that to whom
much is given much is expected and as I
said at the beginning when you think
about giving your own money away it
feels like quite a quite an incredible
responsibility but when you start to
look at the body of somebody else's
life's work and you say my gosh this is
what Warren's done with his life is what
you know bill and I have done with our
lives that coming together it's an
enormous responsibility but it's also
something that we hope that we can you
know live up to and that we'll do our
very best put our best hearts and minds
to it
Warren once said to me a few years ago
long before any of this came about just
when he was looking and we were talking
a lot about what we were doing the
foundation what we're excited about he
said you know it's amazing what you all
do with both rationality and world
empathy and I think that is what we're
trying to stand for with all the
resources that will go
back to society it's just in the last
four or five months that this started to
really come into focus and even then I
think I still thought how is this really
gonna happen and you know today Warren
signed the letter and now we've got a
incredible opportunity to to take full
advantage of that check the second row
here gentlemen in the near the aisle
Edward Chancellor breaking views a
question for mr. Buffett yeah now the
the foundation will be heavily exposed
to Berkshire Hathaway stock going
forward will you consider in the
interests of the long-term of the
interest of the long term returns to the
foundation changing the balance sheet or
the arrangements that Berkshire Hathaway
paying out say your equity portfolio a
dividend or getting rid of some of its
excess capital at some stage in the
future and I only ask that because
you're a great asset allocator but there
may be asset allocators outside of
berkshire hathaway who'd like to get
hold of some of this money at some stage
in the future and invest it on behalf of
the foundation well I do consider as I
put in the letter Berkshire to be in
almost an ideal asset to underpin the
well-being of any foundation now it is
that's one of the reasons I have
arranged the structure as I have because
if if I given the stock outright the
Foundation's they might very well be
criticized for having such a high
percentage of their assets in a in a
single stock this way in effect I can
make the decision as to as to what is
behind these resources that are going to
go to society and and I there will be no
change in any corporate policy at
Berkshire Hathaway because of this we've
always tried to get the best long-term
results for shareholders that we could
and there's even some economic
principles in the back of the Berkshire
annual report that explains that so I
I've always been incentivized to do that
I've always committed to do that and I
think this is
the best way personally to have 40 odd
billion invested that will go back to
society over time they'll be socks that
end up doing better Berkshire there's no
question about that be dozens hundreds
of stocks that wind up doing better but
in terms of being the surest way of
getting a good result that's not the not
the possible way of getting the best
result but the surest way of getting a
good result for society with the ones I
feel good about Archer and we're
thrilled to have it be Berkshire I'm
biased I'm a Berkshire director but
we're thrilled that those are the assets
that will accumulate and create the the
power for the foundation to do more it's
in the tan jacket
Suzanne Pratt nightly Business Report on
PBS my question is for mr. Buffett
following up on an earlier question
regarding the stock can you think of any
reason why Berkshire Hathaway shares
would sell-off on this announcement
today well I don't know about today I
can't think of any reason why they would
sell off their over any period of time
now anytime people get breaking news on
a stock you know i knows how they react
in a given hour or a day or even a week
but i see no way that it decreases the
intrinsic value per share of berkshire
and i see no way that if over time
changes the price of berkshire relative
to its intrinsic value in the market so
i there should be no downside whatsoever
and i can possibly see some upsides over
a period of time just in increasing the
liquidity but that's not a consideration
and and what i'm doing here
mr. Buffett Anthony Mason with CBS you
have said you don't feel as well cut out
to be a philanthropist as the gates are
right why is that well I think they can
probably I think they'll probably spend
more time and energy on it and I am so
involved in what I do I'm having so much
fun doing what I do that for me
to say I'm going to spend a high
percentage of my time in some other area
it's just not realistic I mean I would I
would know it's like me putting Cherry
Coke and hamburgers I mean I think I
think they will be more able to accept
mistakes than I would feel about I have
no problem accepting their mistake
because they're gonna make them and
anybody's gonna make them I don't like
to make them myself so all I would
rather have them make the same mistakes
that I would make and probably some
fewer and I I just I have so much fun
doing what I do that I don't give me a
book last night about how many pages of
there 892 yeah okay and you know he said
I'm giving a quiz on this in the morning
and I yeah he's better when you read way
faster but he he can soak up this
information on a whole bunch of somebody
so much fashion if if you were to if I
were to have unlimited time in the next
year and he were to have unlimited time
and they and we started from the same
point in terms of learning about
medicine you know I would just I would
give him the blue ribbon and go off and
do something else he went that doesn't
bother me it just means he's better at
it than I am
I'm better at managing money than most
people you know and that's what I've
done and people it made sense for people
to turn their money over to me to do
that it makes sense for me to turn the
money over that's going to go into
philanthropy to billable and and I'm
probably I would not want to listen to
as many different people with as many
different opinions as they enjoy
listening to
I love questions from journalists though
I've got time for one more question
Marilyn chase reel and chase from The
Wall Street Journal I'd like to ask the
Gates's you often speak of your grants
not as an end in themselves but being
catalysts that you hope will draw their
partners and draw their funders and
donor governments into the enterprise so
the programs will be scalable taking
that question into the arena of
philanthropy do you see this merging of
your fortunes as being an era the
beginning of an era of mega foundations
and what do you think will be the impact
on philanthropy and what would you like
the impact to be I think they'll
continue to be foundations of all sizes
because it's very appropriate if you
want to solve certain local problems
then small-scale foundation is a great
great way to go do that if you want to
deal with billions of people I and
really get out all over the world then
you probably need more scale to do that
in one way of dimensionalizing what
we've got here it's about 50 Cent's a
year per person or $1.00 per year per
the poor half you know which is it
compared to these problems we're trying
to solve in some ways kind of small and
yet we're optimistic that between what
we do other philanthropists working with
governments that these problems can't
all be solved I hope we're seeing a rise
in philanthropy and that everybody who's
got wealth feels that this is a
something they should do and that they
want to do I hope people have learned
from Warren's philosophy about how we
really owe it to society to give the
wealth back and getting the people who
want to be involved to to do it maybe at
a younger age then when they die now
that goes back to sort of the Gospel of
wealth it's a article that Warren
gave me quite a long time ago in great
great thoughts about about philanthropy
I would just add that I don't think the
wealth all has to be concentrated in one
place it happens to be in this
foundation a very large bulk of wealth
but we will continue to work the way
we're working today I mean we will still
work with the other foundations that
we're working with so closely today and
so many partners that we work with and
we rely on today and I don't think that
that changes just because of the scale
of the money that's involved here it
just allows us to deepen in our areas
and it's something that we're obviously
tremendously thankful to warned about
and tremendously excited about for the
impoverished of the world